hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und ich glaube nicht dass ich das
erwähnen muss aber einfach um es
zeitlich korrekt zu dokumentieren
er hält uns alle zu hause fest die
regeln sind einfach musst du nicht in
den supermarkt bleibst du zu hause so
einfach ist sie anscheinend leider doch
nicht für meinen freund timo tritt durch
den aber ein neues problem ein durch die
schließung der friseursalons wurde seine
standard null acht fünfzehn frisur
langsam zu einer goldenen wilden mähne
und da ich nicht überzeugen konnte sich
die haare bunt zu färben um wie ein
mitglied von bts auszusehen
lucky me in den ohren damit ihm die
haare doch endlich zu schneiden
natürlich mache ich sofort meine chance
portabel bedingungen aufgestellt ich
darf es filmen er reagierte so
sympathisch und nett wie ich ihn kenne
und sagte ich sammelte meine kraft
konzentrierte mich auf meine mission
setzte meine stärkste waffe ein und
sagte er schien so langsam gebrochen zu
sein und antwortete ich hatte keine
andere wahl als meine attacke zu
wiederholen
es erwies sich als sehr effektiv und nun
präsentiere ich euch meinen fast
schönsten tag im leben willkommen in
meinem friseur salon
ich sehe da kam schon der erste kunde
sich doch mal gerne okay ich kann es
nicht glauben dass es dazu gekommen ist
aber kaum gerade dazu bei mixed feeling
ist würde ich mal sagen diese ein
professionelles studio kann ich etwas zu
trinken bieten ein bier haben kaffee in
probiere die berufsrichter extrem oder
gewinn wenig erleichtert und auf dem
präsentierteller behörde unangenehm so
hier ja dafür ist vorzüglich fiebere ich
guck mal nicht ganz so ihre haare an die
ausschüsse ja und sie haben volles haus
in calls also sie habe gesagt alle
friseursalon sind jetzt geschlossen und
wir brauchen aber klarstellt ich sehe
schon die haare
ja das geht ja hier alles übers ohr das
kann ja nicht ruhen im neuen bereich
high ja ja ja die wir heute schon seit
wochen rum
ich werde jeden tag dazu genötigt wurde
kommt kaum gezogen
naja du würdest gerne wollte sich die
die schneide ich habe mich gezwungen vor
der kamera zu machen aber ebenfalls
erwarten also ganz
das erste mal in meinem leben dass ich
wirklich habe schreibe das sollte man
als friseur nicht sagen aber sie sind
geblieben was wollen sie denn noch mal
ja ich über machen seiten 12 und oben
ein bisschen kürzen aber mit übergang
aber wir haben kein gelebt wir haben
dann aber annette k 92 das ist ja so
tumpel
mit übergang also ich muß wenn man
länger ich habe angst aber ich habe es
so schön ist aber für scheiße ausüben
würden
außer ihr aber sonst keiner so wirklich
angenehmen und eine vettel aber ins
gesicht scheint so
sie werden jetzt ihre haare geschnitten
bekommen von einer und ausgebildeten
nicht verkraftbar
das sind 3000 15
ein bisschen mut antrinken gehört
gedacht du brauchst ein gut so ich kenne
ich mal runter schauen wir mal
das fiasko hier
hast du schon recht lange haare die
müssen jetzt weg auf nacken alter mir
tut das wirklich gerade es könnte aber
sein dass der schlimmste fehler meines
lebens war im internet bildet der
erhältst du diese frisur der welt du
musst bisher kaum eine branche
ja ich habe schon einige präsente sie
muss anfangen hinten seite bis hier bis
hier machst du musst du so welche
schaufel ein paar und haben es kein
bagger
[Musik]
er funktioniert du bist vor allem
glücklich sein am ende muss sage
untersuchende hafen künftig spanien eine
12 euro
15 august und eine krone erinnerung
gibt's mit dass meine liebste kurze
erinnerung nicht sagen weil das meine
schlimmsten oder deine liebste dafür
sorgen dass die kosten viel dünner aber
wesentlich schwerer zu schneiden da
diese von der beschaffenheit anders
aufgebaut sind wer so einen einfachen
krimmer hat dem kann ich da man nur
abraten damit die haare zu schneiden
das will gut vorbereitet macht nicht
einmal irgendwie video das land zu
machen oder diesen nach viel zu lang
schritt 2 genehmigt sich machen wir
natürlich haben sind nach china
ausgeliefert
die nächsten wochen
außer ihr aber sonst so schlecht ist das
durchhalten papier durchschneiden
[Musik]
hast du so was los griffigen kleinformat
hierfür ist aber in den zeiten nach kurz
zu machen außerdem mache niemals so oder
so noch von unten nach oben kurz pause
die musik ist zurück aus der pause nie
fühlen sie sich wenn ich würde lügen
wenn die angst ist weg
also ich habe mich jetzt entschieden
weiter mit der schere zu machen um einen
guten übergang hin zu bringen will ist
von dem was ich hier
wenn du dich jetzt wieder schwere ich
habe keine ahnung eine schere die leute
wenn sich geehrt fühlen wenn sie von mir
die haare geschnitten kriegen die beste
technik ich nehme einfach habe sie nach
oben und dem was weg weniger
bei oben und kommen mit nassen haaren
geht macht
aber ich hab sie danach austeilen dann
weil sie dann auch noch die wollen
einfach wie solchen bettenburgen teilen
wir mit den fingern
dann muss man sagen ich habe keinen
spieler jetzt zu sagen wir sind
spielerisch so schmerzlich ins detail
strähnen liegen
ein video wo ich mit meinen haaren
malträtiert werden also wie viele
menschen zu wecken so viel action
das ist der tenor
sie können auch nicht in einen
friseursalon also was mache ich nehme
die haare nach oben und schneiden
einfach fröhlich ab das ist auch gar
nicht so richtig wie viel mehr
abschneidet hauptsache der kunde hat das
gefühl dass man etwas tut tut sich hier
oben aus extrem viele willst du noch mal
irgendwie ausdünnen
das hat keine ausbildung schere sowie
attacke also ich würde sagen da steigt
man kurzinterviews du bist es nicht
nicht sagen
[Musik]
die haare sind nun gewaschen und jetzt
machen wir den feinschliff aber nur eine
hülle in meiner selbst gibt es auch
darum dass alles über mich ergehen
es läuft ihr letztes mal die sonne
kommen das nicht gesagt hat manch soll
die stufen dreht und so kann der fertige
treppenhäuser kommt wenn man mitmachen
kam gerade ja das ist schon ein guter
fortschritt und die bekommen wir machen
ja gerne sagen kann wir machen kann
ja das ist richtig das kabel richtig
maschine die sachen werden produziert
auch mein gott ich sollte nicht die
macht haben provoziert hätte gesagt mehr
zum leben wie ich aussehe verarscht mich
doch nicht selbst auf einen das video
nicht angehen
hier kommt unsere ja drauf fast
unglaublich
[Musik]
die dauert genau zu sehen ob ich das
gemacht hätte
klar ist es in der kamera nicht wir
sagen jetzt einmal den boden du ziehst
du ja was neues ist aber jetzt hier aus
wir sagen du machst dir was rein und
gucken wir
[Musik]
muss aber immer noch erst einmal so sind
wir zu styling benutze ich gab die
deutsche radio handelten wie ok 13
[Applaus]
ich bin einfach schreibt doch gerne in
die kommentare wie findet ihr meine
leistung dauer sein kino als nächstes
meine haare schneiden
timo mit nun vor
es geht es halt nicht so klien aber dass
es noch nie gemacht hast schon zurück
eigentlich feature foto lothar quast
auch mit dem bad romance scamming bad
honnef gedacht was schließlich zur
klassenkasse veränderungen aber es ist
doch immer gut geküsst sein haar ist
remo den weg alleine wird auf dem
präsentierteller schon besser
für die leute sagt einfach danke danke
keine serie von dir kein problem danke
das sind mein video dabei waren ja ich
weiß du bist der beste
sie soll ab juli den kanal und ambo und
vergesst nicht weit kommen
wie schmeckt ich habe ich habe